these are ponchi  or if it's on its own it's a pond check  it's a polish treat made from  deep-frying dough with a stuffed sugary  jam filling  and then it's covered in even more  sugary icing  basically it's the definition of  delicious  wait  don't touch we need to film it first  [Music]  warsaw's a vibrant city with a bit of a  sweet tooth and that's where polsky  comes in  there are a few spots around the city to  get palmski but no more authentic than  here  this tiny bakery has been producing  ponchi since 1925.  which  sylvia's great grandfather created the  secret family recipe which still stays  strong to this day  is  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  um  and on fat thursday the last thursday  before lent boy do they sell a few more  does that explode  eight to ten thousand  [Music]  [Music]  sylvia  nor can we  [Music]